Shazam!
I've never seen the likes of it before
having done james bond for 10 years four films
nothing compares to this
I play hawkman cyclone adam smasher dr fate
leading the whole charge is dwayne johnson
he's more brutal uncompromising
fueled by the depths of his pain
He's black adam
black adam
now what you're going to see here is why
the hierarchy of power in the dc universe
is about to change i hope you enjoy this
very first look at the man in black himself
Black Adam
Welcome back everyone this is going
to be my black adam trailer video the rock
showed up to dc fandom brought a bunch of footage
this is basically the opening scene of the movie
where they reveal black adam for the first time
so we'll break it down there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs and then in a bunch of other footage
that they drop they give you a look at some of
the other characters as well so i'll talk about
them too after i talk about the big opening scene
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'll be doing
videos for all the big trailers today including
the batman trailer later today as well but the
actual opening scene here starts in khandaq in
present day where you have sarah shahi and a
bunch of other characters i believe they confirm
these villains are part of inter gang so even if
they're not the main villains even if there's
some sort of secret villain pulling the strings
behind the scenes inner gang is sort of like the
evil dc group that has taken over this part of
the middle east where khandaq is and black adam
is trying to take it back from them he was going
to rule over khandaq until he got into that big
war with the wizard shazam who trapped him in his
prison here where they release him obviously in a
couple minutes but the whole idea of the movie is
that he's trying to retake control of khandaq and
clean it up the way that black adam thinks that
it should be cleaned up he does care about his
country but he rules with an iron fist that's the
whole difference between him and characters like
superman the justice league characters the justice
society characters which are featured during
the movie in all the shazamly members but you
see sarah shahi's character and these other inner
gang characters come in and they're looking like
they want to actually release him like they're
trying to actively release him you see all these
ornate wall carvings around his tomb it seems like
it's been untouched for the past 5 000 years or so
the crown that you see floating in the air is the
crown that he used to wear before he went into his
prison or for he is forced into his prison by the
wizard shazam you see some very familiar shazam
markings marking his tomb here as she uses the
power word it's the same for black adam as it is
for the shazam lee he says shazam to activate his
abilities but the difference between him and billy
batson the other members of the shazam family is
that he doesn't ever deactivate his powers like
he's always flying around all the time 24/7 with
his powers activated and even though some of the
people that are working on the movie are a little
bit different they want them to look very close to
the same way the powers looked during the shazam
movie they kind of re-tuned things creatively like
they gave everything a little bit of a visual
upgrade from the first shazam film even all the
shazam family members costumes got big upgrades
so they're a little bit more like the black adam
costume you also see the magical energy that he
gives off like this color of lightning is also
a little bit upgraded from the way they did it in
the first shazam movie but effectively it's meant
to be the exact same as the shazam characters the
difference is is that he doesn't share his power
with anybody else so that's why he's stronger in
a one-on-one fight than billy batson shazam for
instance the difference is though is that when
the full shazam family teams up against him then
they're just as powerful as him but none of them
would beat him in a one-on-one fight they'd all
have to tag team him together which i'm sure we
will see eventually when they do a big crossover
movie but they're not going to be featured in
a huge way during the black adam film because
they're mostly just introducing his character in
the justice society and he's not supposed to be
a huge character during shazam 2 fury of the gods
the way zachary levi explained it is they're not
going to do shazam versus black adam till like the
film after shazam two but then after he busts out
he immediately just vaporizes all these inner
gang members using his lightning and i love the
way that they do this without him speaking any
words like he's completely silent but the rope
that he comes out in is exactly like his comic
book rope like it's all kind of tattered because
he's meant to be ancient you have to remember he's
five thousand years old and he's been in prison
this entire time the other cool connection to the
justice league snyder cut the dark side war that
happened in that big flashback that was also about
5000 years ago where all this stuff with darkseid
the forces of earth the anti-life equation was
happening and black adam was in the process of
becoming black adam over in khandaq they also
want to make him look kind of like a dark version
of the wizard shazam with his robes like ancient
wizard but he's trying to give his power to billy
batson but now it's an ancient wizard and he just
wants to wreck everybody that gets in his way so
the whole idea is they're playing him more like
an anti-hero it's kind of like the way they did
venom inside the venom movies where typically he's
thought of as a spider-man villain but really in
all the venom movies they play him more like
an anti-hero i think the idea that black adam
is going to be killing a whole bunch of people
in this movie but he's only going to be killing
really really bad people again there could be
some sort of secret villain pulling the string
some bigger dc villain behind the scenes but they
haven't completely revealed that yet then in that
other footage they give you a look at khandaq in
the past 5000 years ago before he went into his
magical prison contrasted with what it looks like
in present day so it's meant to be the shadow of
its former self and black adam basically wants to
clean it up only the way he knows how obviously
they have pierce brosnan here introducing a lot
of this footage he's playing their doctor fate so
i can't wait to see what he looks like in the
film we get a little teaser for his character
like he's holding the helmet there touching sarah
shahi's forehead this is cyclone's character she's
going to be part of their new version of the
justice society that they're putting together
there's going to be a couple different versions of
their team they'll be the original versions that
they talk about from a long time ago where dr fate
and hawkman were on because hawkband reincarnates
in dr fate is just very old in the film something
happened to their team and then they have to
reform a new one in present day and that's where
the younger characters come in like adam smasher
and cyclone i believe this technology that she's
standing all around like it looks like she's on
a spaceship is meant to be hawkman ship because
he has all this thanegarian technology but the
other cool thing about hawkman and dr fate is that
versions of their characters like a reincarnation
of hawkman and an earlier version of dr fate would
have been alive 5 000 years ago for what was going
on with black adam when he first became black adam
then you see a little bit of conduct and present
day outside of black adam's tomb you see a little
bit of hawkman's costume you see a little bit of
adam smasher's costume there's a couple action
scenes with black adam in the past and in present
day like there's a scene of him in the past before
he's become black adam like look how huge the rock
looks and then he's walking into this big throne
room here this is probably the previous warlord
that was ruling khandaq at the time that he became
black adam we got that whole magical powerpoint
presentation in the first shazam movie about
how he became black adam and how everything went
sideways and why the wizard had to trap him the
whole idea that his wife his family were killed
i believe by this warlord here and that's what
pushed him over the edge and caused him to break
bad the seven deadly sins convince him to release
them then they go around killing all these people
in conduct so the wizard shazam then had to stop
black adam and help re-trap the seven deadly sins
i think that's the way they're keeping black adam
from feeling like a complete psychopath like oh
no he didn't kill all these people it was really
the seven deadly sins that killed all these people
even though black adam will be vaporizing a
ton of really really bad guys during the movie
they do have sequels planned for this movie but
what i am expecting is that there'll be some
sort of post-credit scene tag with the shazam
characters just implying crossover eventually
there also might wind up being some sort of
justice society spin-off movie that they try to
develop or maybe like an hbo max series it'll be
the first time we see their team inside the dceu
and this is taking place inside the dc eu the main
justice league earth just like the shazam movie
did it's just that it's happening in the middle
east just a completely different part of the world
there were a lot of rumors about henry cavill
superman appearing somewhere in the movie i
don't know if that ended up working out because
it's been about a year since i've heard any news
about that but even if he's not in this movie
i think the idea is that the rock really wanted
henry cavill superman back and wanted to fight
him in a movie he's powerful enough inside warner
brothers to make that happen like no i want henry
cavill superman to fight me in black adam too
but everybody just post all your reactions in the
comments below what'll happen is is i'll do my
batman trailer video next that'll be dropping
in a couple hours as i'm posting this video
so make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of that most of the
other trailers i'll do videos for tomorrow as well
too like the flash movie trailer the peacemaker
trailer all the other big stuff if you have any
special requests just leave them in the comments
below but i do love that warner brothers is doing
this now i hope they do this every year while you
wait for everything click here for that brand new
batman trailer video i'll update the link as soon
as i post that video and you can click here for
my brand new spiderman no way home trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!